Luciana is with us welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show Luciana
hi Dave thank you for taking my call I
didn't think I was gonna get through but
I was seeking your advice on something I
am I am thinking about quitting my
full-time job to pursue my business
full-time I have a pretty good job
pretty good income and basically I am
getting very tired of corporate America
and I don't believe what I do you know
what I do but where I am today I don't
believe it's for me
I don't feel ever gonna be happy so I
wanted to see what do you like each
other job with bonus about 200k Jonah
combined with my husband 250 what do you
do i do cybersecurity you do what cyber
security cyber security okay and what's
the new side hustle cyber security
cookie oh good and how much are you
making already on the side uh I own it
with my friends friend slash mentor and
so far up today because we're only doing
hard time
close to 80 K but all that money has
been reinvested into the business I'm
sorry you did this with a friend with my
friend mentor yes we haven't we own the
company together yes Oh yuck I hate
partnerships the only ship they won't
sales a partnership why did you do it
together uh it was his business or Chile
and the hero man
so I own a percentage of the business
now so you don't have anything you say
you don't have any control at all
because you don't know I don't own it I
don't have I don't have the majority no
yeah so he can just
to do anything he wants to do and you
you legally have to go along with it
mm-hmm yep yeah no not theoretically
this and that gum facts
yeah you're jumping out of the fire into
the frying pan I love the idea tu told
me about this I mean if you told me you
were making a tea on the side and I
thought I was going to tell you to turn
it up and go make 150 on the side and
then jump ship and into your own thing
yeah that's great let's do that but into
something you don't even own half of
where he can just decide tomorrow that
you don't work there anymore you're in a
very disadvantageous position you have a
very very weak position you are a little
more than an employee Danger Danger
Danger Danger Danger yeah I would go out
on your own but I would go out on your
own if I were you and you'll build
something and then leave corporate
America that's what I would do I don't
think you're gonna listen to me but I'm
gonna get to talk to you later when this
falls apart after you don't listen to me